we actually have a question for you guys
if you guys want to pick a game for what
we need to bet on oh yeah we actually
have my uh
no way
a little left you got your baseball you
got your basketball you got your
football you can pick anything you can
pick and then the amount is set so at
100. no no let's let's oh
scary don't make one yeah
is that a betting phrase
you never heard that phrase no scared
money don't make money now I've never
heard that oh man is that just like a
phrase in general or is it specific for
betting no no I do that with stocks okay
all these like I do it's like a gambling
thing he watches Ben and Emily's like
scary
that's what people say when they're
trying to get you to buy into something
so yeah there's others bought in yeah I
wanted to see the other sports yeah
you bet on the star stock market
why don't you just
buy the stock
it's not fun though it's like you can
like it's new to this this is options
basically you can just buy it yeah you
better pickles up or down
dude that is hilarious so you can bet on
the stock and then put money in the
stock to win yeah yeah handball is the
one that's sticking out to me dude I
kind of want to make I know there's auto
racing scroll up go to auto racing I
want I know I want to see what car like
classes they have here because I'm sort
of I want to make Walid watch like the
most boring like just the worst like a
race that has like 500 laps and the cars
are slow as [ __ ] there's gotta be more
boring Sports than that um you guys want
my MLB account yeah yeah yeah baseball
is not boring when you're throwing down
yeah I'm sure baseball's also not boring
at all handball hockey keep going horse
racing the lottery betting on the
lottery politics yeah
God yeah yeah yeah the Brazilian
election is going to be a landslide I've
heard it's like pretty corrupt yeah
Governor races oh no yeah
remember we gotta we gotta do something
quicker yeah is there something let's
scroll up September 13th there you go
yeah the Rhode Island Democratic primary
that's it that's that's what I'm voting
on you should have made the rules like
they have to bet on like a baseball you
literally left It Wide Open let's go
back to main sports
anyway these odds are kind of [ __ ] up
though it's like pretty obvious who's
gonna win right yeah well he just has a
hit on like all these like Governors oh
my god dude oh my God guys
Helena folks it's covid right before
can we even like legally joke about that
yes
I didn't say murdered
there you go this is fun right
laughs what is oh odds boosters I don't
know what that is I haven't got that far
all right how about how about baseball
can we pick like Korean baseball or
something uh yeah Chinese Japanese let's
do this and let's get like let's all get
behind one team oh my God I didn't
Samsung Lions dude okay let's read these
when are these games when are these
games all cell phones
these are tomorrow or no yeah these are
tomorrow right this is tomorrow yeah
yeah okay so let's pick one that we like
at 2 30 a.m we're all gonna be watching
feel the Samsung Lions just is funny
that's got a funny ringtone but the odds
are so [ __ ] damn every oh what's that
what kind of like a lot of giants a
whole lot of Giants are they both minus
is that minus 121 minus 109 I mean if
you're if you feel like someone's gonna
win
um then you bet the under but usually I
play it kind of safe and just bet the
most minus that seems to be working out
for you though yeah I'm up
he's got a Tesla in the spaceship
parking lot Samsung lines is just funny
yeah let's bet on them
wait are they favored or what's the
favorite they're the underdog let's go
what's up yeah yeah tell us how much you
would you would bet on this
um
go down go down uh let's do 250 for this
you are great you're crazy let's see
what the odds are for the what's the win
is this ethical we're doing right now
yeah 100
000 a thousand percent money yeah yeah
you're right yeah yeah well I'm
encouraging anyone else to bet this is
walid's money yeah uh you have my audio
confirmation that you could place this
give a thumbs up to the camera thumbs
here we go success there you go you guys
want to do a few more just
dude we should do the Samsung lines
cheer
Samsung
lying there it is
[ __ ]